International correspondent John Sparks
has the latest from caraman marash at
the epicenter of the earthquake and a
warning his report contains pictures of
bodies being removed from the scene of
the disaster
the air is soaked in dust and smoke
the city marked with concrete Mounds
but in this apocalyptic State there is
evidence of life
human beings still breathing in the
rubble
foreign
we saw an Israeli Rescue Team exploring
the remains
one of the first International groups to
reach Caravan Mirage
and they had made a life-saving
discovery
a young woman had been rescued from the
Gloom her name zayap chivi
she was fast asleep when the earthquake
struck dressed in polka dot pajamas and
we could see her shivering and crying
after her three-day ordeal
we're here we're here don't be afraid
said a paramedic
her younger sister elif followed right
behind the 20 year old was also
shivering
[Music]
but The Rescuers were elated and the
family Overjoyed praying for a miracle
they'd been delivered to thank you very
much thank you very much
his name is Burak and he told us he's
the girl's cousin
think that you had lost her or did you
still have hope in your heart we thought
they were dead we'd prepared the burial
plot
the Israelis said the sister's survival
owed much to Chance some information
from an earlier success
yesterday night we pulled out a man
named Hussein he was 65 years old
and he told us that he heard voices
and we penetrated the additional room
and we didn't find anyone
but we decided to return to this
building again
maybe he was right
so it was not so close but we found two
women here
we've just come around the corner it's
the same building but the contrast could
not be any greater these are local
people they are using
crowbars and Spades
to try and get access to the building
they want to do the same thing they're
trying to to save people's lives they're
trying to retrieve bodies but it is
going to take them much much longer to
do it
I'll be they can smell and in some cases
see the bodies but it doesn't mean they
can get them out what is happening here
we can smell a body here says this
volunteer the body is lying on a bed so
we're trying to dislodge it
victims make an undignified trip to a
sports stadium for identification
some go by hand
others in diggers
while the injured go to local hospitals
like this one which has turned its
reception into a giant Ward
here we met a relative of zayap and elif
and we asked him how they were doing
normal no injuries said cousin qasim
chivett but they're bruised and cold and
they're trying to revive them
Specialists and supplies have begun to
arrive here but they can't meet the
demand in this traumatized City
John Sparks Sky News in caraman marash